i'm joined by neil schmidt who's a
foreign policy expert with the spd with
the social democrats here at the german
parliament now uh mr schmidt what is
your reaction to boris johnson resigning
as british prime minister
first of all this is very good news for
british democracy
after all this opens the opportunity for
the conservative party to return to
serious politics for the uk
and at the same time i hope for a better
relationship between the uk and the
european union in the future
what kind of a new leader does britain
need in order for relations between
germany and the uk to improve
i think we need a fundamental shift in
the attitude of the conservative party
vis-a-vis the european union for too
long the eu has been
considered as the main scapegoat for all
the evil that has been
brought about brought upon
great britain
and i think that a closer eu uk
relationship
can offer
many opportunities
for improving the living standards of
the average britain as well
and when you look at the people who are
currently being discussed as potential
new leaders and are there
hopes that this will improve or does
britain need a complete fresh start
well a fresh start can only be
can only come from the labour party of
course we are hopeful that our sister
party
can win the next general election
but for the time being very much depends
on the personality of the next prime
minister
is it another hard brexiteer
or is it rather a sort of neo-liberal
thatcher
that right that might that is interested
in a rational and sober relationship
with the european union and its uh
single market
when you look at labor your sister party
we're not getting the impression here
that they would change anything about
the pro-brexit stance that also boris
johnson's government stood for
that's right after all brexit
found a large or found a majority at the
referendum so we have to respect that
but i think the british government any
british government
should have a
more
sober
a more
rational
attitude towards the european union and
i think that labor is ready
to get brexit done
without giving up on a working
relationship with the european union
and questions like the future of the
northern ireland protocol
can be solved on that basis in a much
better way than
we could have done with the boris
johnson
just how damaged is the relationship
between the european union
and the uk because of boris johnson's
reign as prime minister
very open uh lee i must say that he has
been regarded as a clown and so
i think we need
some serious and honest politics to
get back to whitehall and downing street
number 10.
and i believe that
a new prime minister
should not regard great britain as an
island some aware offshore in the
indo-pacific
after all great britain is part of
europe and the war in ukraine russia's
aggression against ukraine has
demonstrated to us
how important it is to have a close
security cooperation between the uk and
the european union
now talking about the war in ukraine at
some point did you ever think that
his resignation and the
ensuing um continuous debate that is
going to happen in britain now over the
next couple of weeks about who is going
to follow him that that might actually
weaken the west in its unity when it
comes to reacting to events in ukraine
not at all i'm i have full confidence in
the british government
to be able to act
immediately and forcefully if
national security is under threat and
we've seen a large consensus in the uk
in the british parliament on the war in
ukraine and on the need to support
ukraine uh including uh the
the the shipment of weapon veterans to
ukraine so i see no weakening of the
british position on that
newt schmidt foreign policy expert with
the social democrats here in germany at
the parliament thank you very much
welcome
you